i'm sitting here as a son of an
immigrant family a black kid public
school education was able to rise to the
top i hope that 50 years from now we
will all be again one people one nation
one nation under god is our founding
fathers told us we should be
colin powell has died the former
secretary of state was 84 years old
powell's family announced on his
facebook page that he died monday
morning due to complications from kovid
19 adding that he was fully vaccinated
in the statement his family writes quote
we have lost a remarkable and loving
husband father grandfather and a great
american
powell is survived by three children two
grandchildren and his wife alma among
those sharing their condolences former
president george w bush powell became
the first black us secretary of state
under gw's presidency and served in that
role from 2001 to 2005. in a statement
monday president bush praised powell as
a great public servant whose counsel and
experience was relied upon by presidents
of both parties and said he and his wife
former first lady laura bush are deeply
saddened by powell's death quote he was
such a favorite of presidents that he
earned the presidential medal of freedom
twice he was highly respected at home
and abroad and most important colin was
a family man and a friend president
obama called powell an exemplary soldier
and patriot who was at the center of
some of the most consequential events of
our lifetime
as for president and secretary clinton
they called out powell's intelligence
character and the ability to see the big
picture and attend to the smallest
details it's true that powell was a
presidential favorite during his
political career he would go on to serve
in top rolls under four of them first as
a national security advisor to president
ronald reagan and then as chairman of
the joint chiefs of staff under
president george h.w bush and president
clinton the first african american to
ever hold the role in another first e.t
was backstage with powell when he was
the first guest on the then new set of
cbs this morning back in 1995. what's it
feel like to be the first guest on this
new brand new show well it was pretty
exciting we're all learning together and
those four-minute segments go by real
fast i learned that gotta get better
sound bite
what
was the audience how was the audience
the audience was very warm we were all
sort of uh new at this and uh but by
halfway through the show i think we're
all starting to warm up some of them
actually had uh my book my memoirs so we
just had a little mini book signing here
but i enjoyed it very very much
[Music]